c'est le cas de mon premier voeu que la
france se porte mieux économiquement et
socialement bien sûr mais aussi et
surtout au regard l'unité c'était le
thème de cette soirée de cérémonie de
voeux 2016 les départements des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine ont mutualisé
leurs cérémonies
symbole de cette fusion voulue par les
présidents des conseils départementaux
des deux territoires
la danse fait devant une salle comble
d'élus député-maire et personnalités
sportives comme laurent blanc ou le
racing métro c'est de faire de la
mutualisation en faisant des choses qu
on faisait chacun de notre côté en les
faisant ensemble ça coûtera moins cher
un exemple c'est pour ça qu'on commence
par les routes
les appels d'offres qu'on fera
concerneront deux départements donc
forcément des entreprises pour les avoir
son rejet de baisser leurs prix et cette
mutualisation va générer des économies
qu'ils vont être affectés à modérer la
pression fiscale et à financer le
développement économique
il n'y a pas de politique sociale
possible sans développement économique
plus qu'un trait d'union un projet
d'alliance visant à créer un seul et
même département
un calendrier a déjà été annoncé
commençons le 5 février par deux
délibérations concordantes
du conseil départemental des yvelines et
du conseil départemental des
hauts-de-seine
on crée un établissement public
interdépartemental dans lequel nous
allons réunir progressivement nos
services un conseil dont la présidence
devrait être prise par patrick devidjian
réunissant les 88 conseillers des deux
assemblées le gouvernement récolter ce
qu'il a semé
il a créé une métropole qui était ni
fait ni à faire et qui coupait la région
ile de france a dans une frontière qui
n'avait aucun sens il n'y a pas de cours
de frontières entre rueil malmaison et
la celle-saint-cloud entre clamart et et
vélizy donc la vérité c'est que la
réplique des hauts-de-seine et des
yvelines elle est logique
une solution pour pallier les baisses de
dotations globales de fonctionnement
mais aussi contrer le projet du grand
paris qui n'a tué que les départements
de la petite couronne restent encore
attendre l'autorisation de l'état pour
une fusion qui devrait commencer à se
décider dès le 5 février l'opposition du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
quant à elles contestent ce projet et
réclame son abandon